well to be honest I had a very
variegated early career I worked in
various jobs and I at one point I was an
engineer working making airplanes and
while I was studying engineering I
became interested in philosophy and
particularly in those areas of
philosophy which were dealing with the
mind-body problem how things were
represented in the mind and and things
like that and I began to think that it
was just possible that if we understood
more about the brain we will be able to
understand some of the problems which
people had been dealing with prefer
centuries in paignton millennia so I set
out on the course where I decided it
would be great to study the brain in
those days there wasn't anything called
neuroscience there were several people
studying the brain but it wasn't a very
developed subject so i went to back to
university full time and ended up doing
psychology because it was one of the few
areas where you could study study the
brain so i came to the field of studying
brain neuroscience really through my
interest in philosophy and trying to
answer some of the fundamental questions
i think i've been very lucky that it
turns out that i have made a
contribution towards one of those those
questions and i'm very fortunate that
dancer